a factory on a river wants to discharge
its polluted effluent to the nearby
River the factory is proud of its
pollutant removal technology which it
claims can remove 70% of pollutants from
its effluent flows initial concentration
of 75 mg per liter the river has an
existing flow rate of 225 CFS and an
existing pollution concentration of 1 mg
per liter the pollution limits in this
River are not to exceed a concentration
of 3 Mig per liter what is the max flow
rate that the factory can discharge in
million gallons per day so as not to
exceed the river's pollution
limit so this problem is a pretty
classic example of a mass balance
problem that you would find in an
undergraduate environmental engineering
class I don't even think there is an
equation for it in the reference manual
but the closest I found is on page
460 if you want to see an example of a
mass balance equation used for a
slightly different
application the version of the mass
balance equation that we want to use can
instead be written as
follows q1
c1+ Q2
C2 equal
Q3
C3 and in this case Q3 is going to be a
combination of q1
plus
Q2 so let's get into the problem the
question is asking us to find the max
flow rate exiting the factory that will
not cause the in River pollution to
exceed 3 mg per liter so let's start
filling in our know and then see what is
left q1 is what we are solving for so
let's leave it as a variable C1 isn't
given directly but we can solve for it
very
easily the problem states that the the
factory is able to remove 70% of
pollution from its uent which is given
as 75 mg per liter so if 70% is removed
then 30% is remaining this means that
just about 23 mg per liter is leaving
the factory which will be our C1
term note that these terms could have
been C2 and Q2 as as well if you had
called the river's flow and pollution
concentration q1 and C1 instead speaking
of the river it's flow in concentration
is given directly and can also now be
added to our equation so the river's
flow rate is
225 cubic feet per
second and the pollution concentration
is 1 mgram per
liter
now Q3 is going to be the sum of q1 and
Q2 however since our goal is to solve
for q1 we have to write Q3 out in terms
of q1 and
Q2 and since the upper limit of
pollution is given as 3 mg per liter
that is going to be our C3
term from here we can simplify and solve
for q1 very
easily and see that our answer is about
22.5 cubic feet per
second
and finally since the problem asks us
for units of MGD we have to convert our
answer so 22.5 cubic feet per second
time
7.48
gallons per 1 cubic
foot
times 60
seconds in 1
minute
times 60
Minutes in 1
hour times 2 24
hours in one day times 1 M gal over 10 6
gal these units will cancel out out and
multiplying this all the way through
will give us a final answer of
14.54
mgal per day and we can see our closest
answer is the third one over
here so again this is a basic mass
balance problem all you have to do is
set it up correctly and remember to
answer in the correct units and it can
be solved and finally remember that
dilution is not the solution to
pollution